okay his video is really me be on my
soapbox and I am honestly very nervous
and scared about it
but here goes nothing hey everyone how's
it going it's my you go so today we're
going to be talking about feelings and
before we start just wanted to say thank
you again to Squarespace for sponsoring
today's video
whether you need a website domain or
online store make it with Squarespace
okay so I wanted to talk about feelings
today because I realized recently just
how much I feel and how much feelings
and emotions are a strong part of my
personality and so I've been trying to
sort those feelings out and just being
more attuned to how I'm feeling in
different situations and different
moments but because being a software
engineer in the tech industry is also a
core part of my identity I've been kind
of thinking about these two at the same
time and seeing how both affect each
other and so I wanted to open up this
conversation about just feelings and
working in the tech industry with y'all
so I don't know if y'all have felt this
before but I'm definitely thought it it
feels like the general public think that
engineers are emotionless cold-hearted
mechanic and machine like people and I
think the stereotype comes from a lot of
different things like the media yeah
obviously just the media the media is
the worst but yeah I just kind of feel
silly to me because software engineers
are still human beings who feel and
think about different things you know
and I wanted to talk about that a little
bit because maybe there's something
about working in the tech industry
especially as a software engineer that
makes it hard for you to express your
emotions and perspectives freely without
judgment and this just doesn't feel that
great to me like I said before I'm
someone who has a lot of emotions and
feels often very strongly and in a work
setting I'm the type of person who wears
my heart in my sleeve and talks about my
feelings a lot and I like to think this
is beneficial because I bring different
perspectives to different situations
I mean people feel differently about
things based on their background or
personality right and if you think about
the fact that software is usually
supposed to cater to a lot of different
kinds of people having those types of
people in the room talking about their
perspectives I
is really useful because then you
ultimately make a better product and
better software as a result this is
actually one of the main arguments for
why diversity is so important in tech I
also understand that being able to
express your emotions and perspectives
freely without judgment is not something
that everyone has the luxury of doing
and even if you're not in a societal or
economic situation being able to talk
about your emotions and perspectives
like that is something that most people
are only comfortable doing with the
people they trust I don't know maybe
it's just like the fear of being
different and because of all the things
that make up who you are you have a fear
of being rejected and you're afraid that
expressing your emotions is going to
alienate yourself from other people but
I think you'll find that like emotions
are a common human experience and so
sharing those with other people and
finding connections and sorting through
those emotions I think those that's one
of the best things that you can do to I
don't know just figure out how life
works that's why I think that being able
to create safe environments where people
feel comfortable expressing their
emotions is really important and
honestly it's every single person's
responsibility to make that environment
like shutting people down and not being
empathetic to their situation can make
this really difficult being able to pick
up on keys is a big part of this and so
if you see someone who's maybe like
shaking when they're talking in a big
group then they're probably really
nervous and so we're going out to them
and saying like hey you did a great job
you really express your thoughts clearly
is really meaningful to that person or
maybe you see someone who's been wanting
to talk for a while but they haven't had
the chance to opening up to them and
saying like hey I noticed that you've
been wanting to say something for a
while what would you like to say is
something that is so easy to do and
anyone can do and it makes people feel
so much more welcomed I always I hope
you got something from that let me know
what you think I might be wrong in all
of this and so I would love to hear some
differing opinions
I would love to gain some more
perspective on what you all feel because
I am just one person in the tech
industry who has a very you know who's
had a very different background from
probably a lot of y'all so and if I
wasn't clear on any of these ask me I'll
comment I think this is a really
interesting topic and it's something
that's
my mind for a long time now so I wanted
to open up the discussion in here which
I'll think so give this video a thumbs
up if you like these types of videos
where I talk about attitudes and
feelings and thoughts about the tech
industry I love talking about these
things with my friends and so I think
opening it up and broadening the
discussion around this might be pretty
cool and don't forget to subscribe to my
channel as always and hit the
notification about if you haven't done
already to be notified for my new videos
so I'm going to VidCon this week which I
am so so so excited about I went last
year for the first time and that's when
Jarvis and I realized we should make our
own YouTube channel so it's been a year
and I'm stoked to really learn about all
the different things that creators are
doing and what techniques you're using
I'm awesome to be able to hang out with
Jarvis and Jonah and Charlie Marie and
Aimee codes so it's gonna be a great
sign so don't forget to follow me on
instagram for all that and twitter
maybe I love it I don't know but I'm
sure there will be a lot of collabs
again thank you so much to Squarespace
for sponsoring today's video they have
beautiful designer templates that are
ready for you to use and it's an
all-in-one platform so you never have to
install patch or upgrade anything ever
they also have award-winning 24/7
customer service that's right I said
24/7 customer service which is one of
the best things I think is also really
easy to set up or transfer a domain on
to Squarespace so you can brand it with
whatever you like it's also never been
easier to set up an online store on
Squarespace so head to Squarespace comm
to start your free trial and when you're
ready to launch go to Squarespace comm
slash my eco for 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain I think
that's it for today so I'll see you next
time
[Music]